hey it's justine and i have been having
so much fun this year reviewing all
kinds of different types of computers
desktops all-in-ones and a ton of
laptops so i am very excited to partner
with hp and intel to showcase this
spectre x360 for you guys today so first
we need to unbox it
[Music]
[Applause]
we've got a box inside of a box
did you see that move did you see it i
saw it i felt it hold up wait a minute
look at this
i have thrown something that i might
need
a little cover
okay
look at that that smells like a real
premium
piece of material
if you ask me
guys look at this this is like a gold
brass color
oh
we have opened up a treasure chest it's
got a little blanket
keep it warm for cozy sweater season
okay
all right
um i'm kind of freaking out because look
at this these beautiful edges it's like
a rose gold oh my if i made a computer
and i picked out everything this is what
it would look like
feast your little peepers on that wow
holy
moly what else is in here
plug into wall okay i think i can handle
that
yes this is the braided cable that i
love so much i first saw this in
the hp enterprise video that i did
reviewing a bunch of laptops and this
was my favorite cable it's just look at
this it's so cool so you got the power
brick and the charging cable
what's in here
that sounds like some candy or something
no it's the hp pen
look at this oh
oops
careful if you do decide to get this
because those little extra tips are
inside of the box i love this box so
much that i'm saving it that's going in
the collection
so one of the exciting things is the
spectre x360 features the intel evo
platform so this has a new 11th gen
intel core i7 processor and you're also
going to be getting amazing performance
for multitasking video photo editing
basically whatever it is that you need
to do like you know watching content and
also playing video games
[Music]
the new intel evo platform will give you
the peace of mind knowing you're getting
a laptop with exceptional responsiveness
real world long battery life instant
wake fast connectivity with thunderbolt
4 and wi-fi 6. when you're looking for a
new laptop you'll know that you're
getting all of these premium features
when this intel evo badge is present see
there it is
oh look at this what is that what is
this what are you telling me
i can put my little pen there
so this is a 13 and a half inch oled
touch panel and this also folds
just like this so you can use it as a
tablet and i love these types of laptops
because you're able to do so many
different things with it look at this i
keep getting sidetracked by looking at
how cool these colors and designs and
angles are i mean you add rose gold
accents to anything
it's like
when you go fishing for like a specific
type of fish and you put the kind of
fish
that they like like this was this is
what they're doing to me
yes
put this
on a fishing pole you're gonna catch
yours
we should probably turn this on now
because i
i can't get any more hyped up than i
already am so depending on where you
purchase this laptop there are many
different configurations but this one is
currently specced out with 16 gigs of
ram it also has a one terabyte solid
state drive and this is going to give
you really fast read and write speeds
it's got the bang olufsen speakers i
love the speaker design it just looks so
good so this also has intel iris xc
graphics and this is going to allow you
to launch apps faster and give you a new
level of graphics and performance in
such a small thin and light laptop
setting up our fingerprint sensor i love
that this has like a pretty large
fingerprint
scanner area right here
i'm also loving this top down shot i
mean i can take my laptop and fold it
backwards and you can see both my
keyboard and the display
it's revolutionary so i've now got
everything all set up i'm so excited to
test this out one of the things that of
course we have to do first is i've gotta
go watch my own youtube videos i just
gotta see how it looks on here it's very
important business so the screen looks
really good it's super bright especially
even in this situation like we have a
lot of lights in here you're still able
to see it very clearly
i love that we can just fold this up
like look at this tablet mode
it's here
it's got auto rotate on i really like
this tablet mode
it's very light so we have a usbc port
over here there's also a 3.5 millimeter
headphone jack secret usbc
right here
on the corner
that's probably the perfect spot
for it to charge
and then we also have another usb a port
here
for all of
the things that we need to plug in so
the speakers sound pretty good on my
video but what we really need to test
out is let's play a nice royalty free
track for you all ready take it away
royalty free track from the internet
[Music]
i feel like i probably should have
picked like a more epic of a song
[Music]
let's see what it sounds like from over
here
[Music]
sounds pretty good
beats about to drop
oh this is great oh god i love this
laptop so much i'm freaking out let's
test the webcam i need to make a call
using a web conferencing service of
which i will not name so we're having a
very important meeting this is my hp uh
all-in-one it's my favorite this is what
i use for streaming
um
when i
when i'm streaming
this is what this is the
it's a nice
setup for when i'm streaming it's very
very important business meeting
i'm just really happy with this so far
it's working my pen check this out so
this is the hp stylus pen and because
this can be used in tablet mode you can
basically be using this to take notes um
i'll take your order please this writes
so nice
cheeseburger
check
for my cheeseburger i'm going to need
some
lettuce
some herbs
i have an herb garden now in case you
guys didn't know
um i'm gonna need
extra
cheese
and just in case i forget
i'm gonna
oh that was supposed to be yellow
that was supposed to be cheese but the
cheese has gotten moldy
because i have left it
out of the refrigerator
oops moldy cheese
i mean isn't cheese just mold anyway so
technically
okay this writes very nice
wow
so
cool
thank you guys so much for watching i'm
so glad i was able to show this to you
because this honestly is such a
beautiful laptop not only are the specs
amazing the screen looks incredible the
sound is awesome but this design is
honestly something that i'm so into so
if you do want a very nice well-designed
pc laptop i think this is definitely one
that you should check out i'll see you
guys in my next video bye
[Music]
you